we're on problem 68
and they want to know what is the
average arithmetic or arithmetic mean of
j and k so average
of j
and k
so essentially if we knew what they were
you could take j plus k and divide by
two and you'd know their average what is
statement one
statement one tells us the average of j
plus two and k plus four is eleven so
this is interesting so the average of j
plus 2 and k plus 4 is 11. so that means
that j plus 2
plus
k plus 4
over 2 i'm just averaging the two
numbers so they're telling us that that
is equal to
that is equal to 11. and remember the
question they're asking is the average
of j and k so if we could just figure
out what j plus k over 2 is equal
to we're done or if we just knew what j
plus k is we were done so i maybe we
could figure that out from this let's
see if we can simplify so you get
this simplifies to j
plus k
plus 6
over two is equal to eleven
this simplifies to
j plus k
over two
plus
three right plus six over two i'm just
taking this 6 over 2 out so plus 6 over
right
is equal to
11. so then we get j plus k
over 2 is equal to 8 and we're done the
average of j plus k j of j and k is 8.
we're done statement one alone is
sufficient let's see what statement
number two does for us
statement number two
says the average
of jk and fourteen is ten i suspect
we're going to be able to do the exact
same thing
so the average of j plus k
plus 14
so now we're averaging three numbers
is equal to 10
right
and here we should be able to figure out
what j plus k is again
let's multiply both we don't have a
convenient 2 in the denominator anymore
so let's just solve for j plus k so then
you get
j plus k
plus 14 multiply both sides by 3 is
equal to 30
and then you get j plus k
is equal to what subtract 14 from both
sides is equal to 16.
and then if you wanted to figure out the
average of the two you just divide both
sides by two
and you get j plus k
over two is equal to 8. so each
statement alone was sufficient to solve
this problem
next problem
i feel the sneeze coming on
this is not happening
all right where was i problem 69
let me move the scroll bar up all the
way
paula and sandy were among those people
who sold raffle tickets to raise money
for club x
if paula and sandy told sold a total of
100 of 100 of the tickets how many of
the tickets did paula sell okay so
essentially they're telling us
paula
plus sandy sold 100 tickets
and they want us to figure out
how many did paula sell
where p is the number paula sold and s
is the number sandy sold
problem number one sandy sold two thirds
as many of the raffle tickets as paula
did
so sandy
is equal to two-thirds times paula
well this alone is sufficient we have
one
one equation of two unknowns and now we
have another equation of the same two
unknowns these are both linear equations
so we have two equations of two unknowns
we can easily now solve for s and p and
maybe i'll do it but you should just
already recognize that this is
sufficient if you're on the gmat and
we'll solve it just to do it
after this
sandy sold eight percent of all the
raffle tickets sold for club x
all right now this is a little different
this is sandy
is equal to
eight percent
of not
not all the all the tickets that sandy
and paula told she sold eight percent of
the total
that club x sold
so this is a different number than
because you know there could have been i
might have been in club x selling raffle
tickets so we don't know how many i sold
so we don't know what this total number
is so this is actually there's not much
we can do with it because there's no way
for us to figure out this total number
so this is not that useful so statement
one alone is sufficient and just to
prove the point to you right we're
trying to figure out what paul sol so
let's just substitute this back in
so you have p
plus
for s i'll write two thirds p
is equal to 100
and so this is
what this is five thirds
p is equal to 100 just added one plus
two-thirds or three-thirds plus
two-thirds
and then you have p is equal to
three-fifths times 100 which is equal to
60. so that's how many she sold so we
would definitely be able to figure it
out but this would have been a waste of
time if you were taking the gmat for
real you should have just recognized two
linear equations and two unknowns i'm
done
next problem
is ax equal to 3 minus bx so a
x is equal to
minus
bx who knows
problem statement number one let me
scroll down a little bit
statement number one tells us
x
times a
plus b
is equal to three
well that's essentially the same thing
as this top equation right let me show
you let's just multiply let's see that's
that says that x times a that's a x
plus b x
is equal to 3 and then subtract b x from
both sides you get ax is equal to 3
minus bx which is exactly what we were
trying to prove so if this is true then
this is definitely true statement 1
alone is sufficient
statement 2 tells us
a equals b
equals 1.5
and x is equal to 1. well let's see if
this is true so
as you have 1.5 times 1 so you have 1.5
is equal to 3
minus 1.5 times 1. so 3 minus 1.5 well
this is true 1 1.5 is equal to 3 minus
1.5 is 1.5 so 2 alone is also sufficient
so the answer is
d each statement alone is sufficient to
solve this problem
71 let me switch colors
a number of people each wrote down one
of the first 30 positive integers
were any of the integers written down by
more than one of the people all right
that's interesting so are any repeats
any repeats
a number of people so clearly if you had
more than 30 people and they all had to
pick a number but one of the first 30
integers then you're going to have
repeats but let's see what they tell us
the number of people who wrote down an
integer was greater than 40. well there
you go number of people
greater than 40. so 40 people each have
to pick a number between
the right one of the first 30 positive
integers right so they only have a pool
of 30 to pick from so 40 people have to
pick numbers from a pool of 30 numbers
there's definitely going to be repeats
right
so even if the first 30 people
all pick different numbers which we
cannot guarantee by any means
the next 10 are going to have to repeat
with somebody because all the first 30
would have already been picked and you
could very easily have even more repeats
so statement number one is very is very
sufficient
statement number two the number of
people who wrote down an integer was
less than 70
number of people
well that's useless less than 70. i mean
this
this statement by this statement maybe
only one person wrote down an integer
right and if only one person wrote down
an integer we definitely don't have any
repeats because there's no one to repeat
with so this is a useless statement so
statement one alone is sufficient and
statement two is useless
73 i think there should be a a third
option where you can rate the degree of
uselessness of a statement
some of them borderline on almost being
useful some of them are ridiculous like
this one
okay 73
i don't know what am i oh that no i'm
172.
72.
and the figure above is cd
greater than bc so they drew us a number
line
or whatever you want to call it some
type of a line let me do another color
this end we have a
and we have
b
then we have
c
and then we have
d
and the figure above is cd so this is cd
greater than bc so they want to know is
this greater than this so cd
greater than
bc
all right
so number one they tell us that a d
a d is equal to 20. so this whole thing
whole thing is equal to 20.
so that doesn't help me much right
statement number one
statement one tells a d is equal to 20.
that just tells me the whole length
maybe i can get some more information
statement number two a b
is equal to c d
a b
so this is interesting they're say
they're telling us that this
is equal to this
but this still doesn't help us right i
mean i can imagine a situation where
both of these are
let's say that both of these are
five
that could be five that could be five
and then this would be ten right five
plus ten plus five
in which case
c d would not be greater than bc right
so this would this would be a situation
that meets all of the conditions where
cd would not be greater than bc but then
i can construct one where it is greater
than bc
i can make cd equal to what if that was
eight
and then this one was also has to be
eight and then we would only have four
left
where cd is greater than bc so in this
case both statements together are still
not sufficient so the answer is e
and i've run out of time i'll see in the
next video